[موسيقى]
لقاح نوفافاكس covid19 الذي
يعتمد على البروتين وتم إنشاؤه
بطريقة تقليدية باستخدام تقنية
تختلف عن اللقاحات الثلاثة المستخدمة بالفعل
في الولايات المتحدة بشكل عام ، كلما كان
لدينا أفضل من نوفافاك يقول إن جرعتين
من لقاحه توفران حوالي 90  فعالية النسبة المئوية
في حماية الأشخاص الذين يبلغون من العمر 18 عامًا
وأكثر من كوفيد 19 ، ومع ذلك فقد
أجريت التجارب السريرية قبل أن
يصبح أوميكرون هو البديل السائد في الولايات المتحدة
، وشملت التفاعلات الضائرة الأكثر شيوعًا
الصداع والغثيان أو القيء
وألم موقع الحقن والتعب ، وهناك
أيضًا بعض الأدلة على حدوث تورم نادر
في  القلب الذي تم الإبلاغ عنه أيضًا في
بعض الأحيان لدى الأشخاص الذين حصلوا على أحد لقاحات covid19 الأخرى ، تم
تصنيع هذا اللقاح
باستخدام قطع صغيرة من
فيروس كورونا في المختبر لتحفيز المناعة ،
وأعتقد أنه لا يزال هناك بعض المعاقين الذين
قالوا إن النظام
الأساسي هو منصة mrna  جديد جدًا و novavax
يأمل مسؤولو صحة التكنولوجيا الأقدم في
جعله أكثر جاذبية
للأشخاص ذوي الإعاقة  لديك مخاوف بشأن التكنولوجيا الأحدث في
الوقت الحالي ،
حيث تم تطعيم حوالي ثلثي السكان بشكل كامل
بسلسلة أولية على الأقل ، لكن أقل
من الثلث حصلوا على معزز
وفقًا
لمركز السيطرة على الأمراض إذا أعطت إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) إذنًا للاستخدام في حالات الطوارئ ،
تتوقع نوفوفاكس شحنتها الأولى  إلى الولايات المتحدة
لتكون بضعة ملايين جرعة للدقيقة الصحية
أنا ماندي جيثر